pinky are you pondering what I'm
pondering I think so brain but how can
you have a duck dynasty if none of the
people are ducks ah dammit pinky can't
you get at least one fucking thing right
what no no cat Mews not the music I have
put up with this bullshit
for too long oshi you are the syphilis
to everything I've worked so hard for
you miserable poisonous sack of diseased
brain shut it bitch I could have had the
world years ago if you didn't keep
fuckin it up oh dear uh give me a favor
and just just die just die for the sake
of all humanity
oh yes that's all you're good for is
what are you sure this is for a kid show
it just say if people want to hear this
for years
oh really all right yeah okay oh you are
pestilence how about you Little Miss
students of life we believe in homicide
I could go back in time to the moment of
your conception
you